unintentionally we pretty much created
this new language that can combine still
with with video
what you've seen here is basically the
technique that we used for more than
thousand words the film that i made
about XIV right before we started we
knew one thing that I could not get
close to xiv in many of the situations
that we film because it draws too much
attention to tues even to the from the
subject that he film
we had to have a mechanism meaning a
miniature camera that could be set up
really quick and that could film him and
the his point of view at the same time
I'm going to connect to our cause it's a
recording machine for audio and video
I'm going to connect a small camera it's
not microphone that I built here this is
what connects this to the camera to the
controller and to my camera so ever i
shoot i have both video and still at the
same time and you can hear the sound to
hear
to give the viewer the ability to see
some of the background of how I think or
how I shoot or where's the decisive
moment that I decided to actually press
the shutter which I find pretty amazing
i wish i could see that on other
photographers which I admired think
their work is great and I would like to
see a bit of the background of how
things were done xiv is like like a fly
on the wall he has to disappear in the
situation that he films because it is a
documentaries i first get a selection of
photos of the day and i have to match
this is the wave where the click is so
you know that here a picture was was
taken so you just met you never knew
that you never did so you can actually
not only edit not only use the wave file
to find exactly where the cliq was taken
by zip but you can also choose your cut
with the video and frames together to
edit the sequence in a rhythmic way
so basically this technique to make a
match frame to the video was something
that we really loved because first of
all I don't think it's never done before
and it was astonishing result and you
know it was again it was not a cosmetic
idea it was something that was derived
from the fact that we could not get too
close to Z while he was shooting his
frames I think it gives a great
opportunity to create a new application
for Internet while in a newspaper you
can only have a still image and on the
web you're able to have to put motion
and sound into still imaging
you